hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast dred 2.0 an enhanced chemo
genetic toolkit I am Julia O'Rourke of
lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this presentation has been approved for
a category 1 continuing medical
education credit by a Loma Linda
University if you're interested in
obtaining CME's after attending this
presentation please click on the get
your free CME credits button in the
bottom left corner of the event screen
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on green shoe and a button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
CRNA button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Brian
Roth Brian L Roth MD ph.d is the Michael
Hooker distinguished professor in the
department of pharmacology at the
University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill Medical School dr. rock has
published early 400 papers and has given
hundreds of invited talks among the many
honors and awards dr. rod has received
he notes his recent election to the
Institute of Medicine of the National
Academy of Sciences I will now turn it
over to dr. Roth for his presentation
thank you so much it's great to you so
much it's great to have another time to
present updates on Dredd technology and
what I'd like to do today is briefly
give a overview of Dredd technology and
then to focus on some recent advances
that give us an insights into how
and other chemo genetic technologies
could ultimately be used as
transformational therapeutic indications
for neuropsychiatric diseases and one of
the things I'd like to highlight today
is that all of the work that I'm
presenting today is supported by the NIH
and in particular the this new brain
initiative grant that we received
through the kind generosity of the
National Institute of Health the other
thing I'd like to point out is that
there will be - brain initiative
presentations tomorrow one by Walter
corsets from ni MDS at both at 3 p.m.
Pacific time the other by Justin Sanchez
from DARPA and these will be very
interesting from a programmatic
perspective now the background thread
and other new interventional
technologies or decoding the nervous
system come from a seminal paper that
was published by Francis Crick some
years ago this was his last major
scientific publication and what he said
was needed back then it was very
prescient was that we needed to do
several things to understand how the
nervous system worked and ultimately to
be able to modulate with therapeutic
purposes the first was to identify the
various neurons and types of neurons
that are in the brain and the other
thing that would be needed is some way
to turn these neurons on or turn them
off in in freely moving animals in a
relatively rapid manner and the
technology the technology that I'm going
to preview to them today is is our
approach for doing this and this idea of
Crick's was given a huge boost by by the
nih and the obama administration where a
new initiative has has been developed
which proposes to transform how we
understand the brain and
ultimately the goal of this is to
understand how each neuron in the brain
works in an ensemble way in real-time to
modulate behavior so with that by way of
background I want to I want to present
how how we initially became interested
in this problem now many years ago but
the idea was that if we could if we
could manipulate neurons what one way to
do this would be to create a receptor
that could be only activated by a small
molecule based ligand or chemical
actuator that was selected for this
engineered receptor and then our idea
was that we could use emerging chemical
genetics or genetic technology to put
that receptor into distinct neurons in
the brain and then to basically turn
them on and turn them off with these
chemical actuators so this was this was
our idea and this was this is an idea
actually that my lab has been working on
since the early 90s I would say
basically without success until a
brilliant postdoc came into my lab in
the early 2000s named Lane Armbruster
and and the project I gave him was we
had we had attempted to do this for many
years by engineering receptors to
interact with new synthetic ligands and
I thought maybe we could do this in the
more efficient way and perhaps one of
the key things would be to start out
with a ligand which was absolutely a
nerd and so he chose this drug like
molecule clozapine and oxide as the
ligand for for these designer receptors
and again Blaine was the person that
took on this project the reason we chose
clozapine and oxide was we were really
thinking ahead to ultimately translating
this technology to primates into humans
and to do this we needed a chemical
actuator which had really good drug like
properties and clozapine and oxide was
the first one we thought this would be a
great initial initial tool because it
has excellent oral bioavailability
excellent CNS penetrability and it's
safe in humans so that ultimately if the
technology was useful we could
ultimately translate it to humans now
the other thing that we knew about it
was that it was pharmacological inert
and the way we we decided to create
these designer receptors was to use a
technology called directed molecular
evolution and we use the model organism
yeast as a platform to do this and this
work has been published you can see the
the citations there and I think a copy
of the presentation will be available
from from this group afterwards but
basically we used error prone PCR to
generate hundreds of thousands and
millions of mutants we then through the
power of yeast genetics basically are
able to grow the yeast on media which
contain the chemical actuator that we
ultimately wish to evolve the receptor
to and then we simply look for receptors
that that activate the pathway leading
to East growth identify the mutants
isolate the classmates and then we
repeat this and this is a fairly robust
process we can screen literally millions
of yeast within a week by a single
highly competent student or postdoc and
so we did this we use muscarinic
receptors as the initial platform
because they have previously been shown
to work very well in yeast and we were
able to obtain a family of mutant
muscarinic receptors that had basically
two point mutations in highly conserved
residues in the receptor which you can
see here and these are conserved among
all muscarinic receptors all the way
from humans all the way down to cassava
and so it opened up the potential to
make families of muscarinic receptors
that could be activated by this inert
ligand clozapine and oxide and in fact
that's what we have done
and they've been validated actually to
work in all model organisms as well as
all mammalian species including primates
and to cut a long story very short what
we were able to do initially is to make
three flavors of these designer
receptors which we dubbed Reds for
designer receptor exclusively activated
by designer drugs one which activates
intracellular calcium and leads to burst
firing another which activates GI
coupled receptors leads to beta gamma
mediated inhibition of activation of
potassium channels as well as an
emission of neurotransmitter release
leads to very nice neural in addition
another one which increases cyclic GMP
and modulates signaling so we call these
the GQ the GI and the GS thread and for
further information you can go to our
website drug org all of the plasmids
that we have created are available from
a gene for a nominal fee and viruses
that we have made to express the dreads
in various brain regions are available
from the University of North Carolina
vector Center again for a nominal fee so
we've done a lot basically to put these
out into the public domain these are all
available without a material transfer
agreements so what I'm going to do is
tell you a little bit about each of
these and then get on to some new
technologies so the first one that we
characterized in bebo was the GQ dread
we noted that it increased intracellular
calcium and suggested that it would
induce burst firing neurons and these
were initially described in a paper we
published in neurons some years ago and
the work that we're doing on them now is
funded by the brain initiative as I said
now what we wanted to do was to
initially validate these in vivo
so we created mice which would express
them under control of an inducible tent
based system and let me just say here
that all of the mice that I'm going to
be describing today as well as newly
created conditional dread mice are all
available from Jackson labs again
without material transfer agreements to
academic labs and nonprofits so the idea
is with the double transgenic Mouse we
can use a particular driver mouse to get
tissue-specific expression in the
absence of tetracycline this drives the
expression of the receptor in a
particular region of the brain or body
and then we just inject sino and this
causes some behavior which we can then
monitor so the first thing we did was
because even though our dreads were
expected to be relatively inert we
wanted to validate this we express them
at extremely high levels using a cam
kinase 2 driver you can see here these
were studies were done by Sarah Rogan in
my lab we could turn it off with
doxycycline and they were highly
expressed in pyramidal neurons and you
can see here as well expressed in the
apical dendrites of pyramidal neurons
very interesting subcellular
distribution now one of the questions
that we get frequently is does basal
expression of the dread
receptors have any effect on baseline
neural firing and baseline behavior and
to date we haven't we haven't seen any
despite great efforts that we have
undertaken to determine if there's a
baseline phenotype they appear to be
silent but and you can typically that
data is found in the Supplemental
portions of our paper but for this
particular Mouse we did a formal
behavioral phenotype being weight gain
feeding or normal
elevated plus maze was normal there was
a small phenotype in in an open travel
in the novel environment rotor rod was
normal acoustic startle was normal
repulsed inhibition was normal and so on
in all respects the mice were completely
normal
except when they were given see you know
the other thing is is because of the
increasing number of genetically
engineered mice we get very nice cell
specific expression berrykin sees an
attempt driver we were able to get very
good expression in glutamatergic neurons
and complete exclusion from GABAergic
neurons for example you can see
parvalbumin neurons here in your zone
there's a close-up of that and through
the brain initiative again a number of
these genetically engineered mice will
be available and what we found was that
CNO induced a relatively robust
depolarization in pyramidal neurons and
in no effect in control neurons this
effect was appeared to be mediated by
sheikhan signaling because was totally
blocked by inhibiting phospholipase c
and importantly what an induced was a
tremendous increase in firing of the
neurons so what the GQ dreads do is they
induced a relatively small but
significant increase in depolarization
but then they basically primed the
neurons to be shown an increase in
spontaneous firing so unlike opto
genetic technologies which induce a very
sort of regular and precisely timed I'll
be an unnatural firing of the neurons
what what the GQ dread does is it it
basically crimes the neuron to increase
its spontaneous activity we further
characterized this by multi-electrode
array studies and freely moving vice
these studies were done
with George Alexander Georgia Alexander
who's now at nie chess in her own lab in
gymnic McNamara Duke and what we found
was that there was a when mice were
injected with with CNO which was
expressed in parameter neurons there was
a huge increase in firing and in some
cases this this effect was so large that
mice had the induction of seizure so the
the increase in firing was was very
similar to essentially depolarizing the
hippocampus the other thing we were able
to do was to determine if if the
expression of the dread had any untoward
effects on the nervous system and so we
because we were using this inducible and
reversible tet driven system we were
able to take the mice off put the mice
on doxycycline for about a month period
of time and then administer CNO and what
we found in those cases was there was
absolutely no effect on firing so
there's a question and what diseases do
the burst firing relate to epilepsy yeah
so if you express the dread in huge
numbers of neurons in the brain then
basically what happens is seizures if
the dread is more sort of tightly
expressed in single neuronal populations
which is the typical way that is that's
done what happens is you basically have
an increase of neuronal firing which is
which which would not be related to any
specific disease but would be similar to
a situation in which you're activating
that that particular pathway but to get
back to these experiments here
again these were these were control
experiments but again very important
controls because they address a number
of questions which frequently come up
related to dread technology whether the
drug clozapine and oxide has any
off-target effects you can see in mice
that are on doxycycline where the dread
is expression is suppressed there's
absolutely no effect and the effect of
the dread has has no long-term effects
on their own oral function and these
results dinner are tabulated here so
with that by way of introduction about
the GQ dread what I want to do is show
some specific applications of dread
technology and show you how it can be
used to deconstruct the activity of
ensembles of neurons in the brain and
then toward the end of their talk show
how dreads potentially can be used in
therapy context and initially what I
want to do is focus on the problem of
the regulation of feeding of course
there are a number of diseases related
to obesity and it would be very very
important sort of going forward to
create medications that would be
effective anti obesity agents but before
we could do this we what we really want
to want to understand is the neuronal
circuitry which is responsible for
regulating feeding and as recently as
four years ago before the revolution
afforded by chemo genetic and opto
genetic technology it was thought that
feeding was a very complex motivated
behavior and it was it was thought that
that we would we would never understand
the precise brain regions that are
involved in regulating feeding and and
as well it was thought that there was no
single stimulation of a particular
neural pathway that could trigger
feeding behavior with any certainty
what was known from from sort of the
distant past was that there are certain
areas of the hypothalamus in particular
that when stimulated with electrical
stimulation could robustly induce
feeding thus stimulation of the medial
lateral and and medial portions of the
hypothalamic area typically were noted
to induce a greatly increased feeding
and it was thought therefore that there
probably are feeding centers located in
neurons in the hypothalamus however the
the problem with with these early
studies which is shown here is that when
neurons are or neuronal areas are
electrically stimulated you not only
activate this green neuron here which
might be responsible for regulating
behavior you also activate the red
neuron as well as axons in passage and
because of this because there was no way
to specifically activate a distinct
neuronal population before the advent of
chemo and optogenetics it was thought
that we would not be unable to ever sort
of disentangle the various neuronal
contributions to the regulating
regulation of feeding by way of
introduction it was known that there are
certain neuronal populations that were
thought to be important for regulating
feeding in particular the agouti related
peptide neurons in the arcuate nucleus
were thought to regulate feeding but the
precise way that they did this was I
would say completely unknown so what my
lab did in collaboration with Brad
laurels lab at the NIH or at Harvard
using with a extremely talented postdoc
of his Mike crashes and my student Sarah
Rogan was to make was first to create
viral vectors suitable for interrogating
this pathway so we basically adopted a
technology which had been pioneered by
Scott Stenson at Genelia Labs to use
lawyer called double inverted loxp sites
called flip or d io base vectors in
which the gene of interest that you want
to introduce into a specific neuron is
is put in the vector and the reverse
orientation so that under normal
circumstances it's not being expressed
and then the viruses are injected into a
brain region of a mouse where career
recombinase is expressed under control
of a specific neuron promoter
this causes recombination and now the
expression of the cargo in the sense
orientation in this case the dread and
the sense orientation of what we can do
is get very nice recombination only in
those neurons that are expressing create
and this allows for the specific
expression of the dread only in this
case in agouti elated peptide receptor
neurons and so these experiments were
done so using an AGR Petri that was
created by Brad Lowell the Dredd virus
which was created by Sarah Rogan was
injected by Michael crashes into the
region of the arcuate nucleus and you
can see here that only a GRP neurons
were expressing the dread and when
slices were made there was this initial
depolarization in them in this increase
in spontaneous electrical activity of
the neurons which which sort of mimics
bursting of neuronal activity by
endogenous GQ coupled receptor so you
get this very nice increase in
spontaneous neuronal activity by the GQ
dread and surprisingly to us there was
this huge increase in spontaneous
feeding which you can see in the red and
the other the other lines are basically
the controls and in about a two-hour
period of time a 18 gram Mouse was able
to increase his his food intake such
that he was
about 1.2 grams of food this would be
equivalent to URI sitting down and
consuming 10 to 20 pounds of food in a
in a relatively short period of time so
this is an extremely robust feeding
behavior that's that's activated only by
activating those neurons in the only
does a GRP neurons in the arcuate
nucleus the other thing that was
interesting was that not only was
feeding behavior activated but the
motivation to eat was also intensely
activated that that could be measured
here by looking at the breakpoint
analysis you can see that the CNO caused
a huge effect in breakpoint analysis
breakpoint or the willingness to feed
willingness to do work to feed and and
the increase in this was basically
equivalent to the motivation to to eat
by a mouse that had been fasted
overnight so that there's a huge
increase in the willingness to eat as
well there was a large increase in in
spontaneous locomotor activity in mice
that did not have free access to food
and so there was this basically this
entire behavioral program that was
induced by activating these a GRP
neurons and and to us this was very very
surprising essentially unprecedented I
note that the horvath lab has a paper
that's in impress and sell its it's now
online where they basically have
replicated this reason this result and
expanded it to show that there's an even
greater repertoire of behaviors that are
seemingly activated only by activating
those those particular neurons in the
brain now at the same additionally there
were relatively large effects of large
peripheral metabolic effects of
activating these neurons a decrease in
whole body oxygen consumption
and chronic treatment with CNO inducing
feeding also led to a large increase in
fat mass so there there were relatively
robust effects not only on on metabolism
acutely but also chronically again only
by activating these individual neurons
again prior to the period these these
studies were done this is this was
basically unprecedented and quite novel
information although now I would say two
or three years later relatively routine
findings in the literature so so what
this showed then was that in fact the
urge to eat as well as a large number of
other motivated behaviors actually are
encoded appeared to be encoded by
distinct neuronal populations in the
brain I want to briefly describe the one
of the other dreads that we created this
is the GI based red hm4 di which causes
neuronal silencing you can see you can
see the whole cell recording here again
this can also be expressed in a cell
type-specific fashion and using the GI
drought again in in these neurons if you
look at the right set of panels you can
see that CNO decreases spontaneous
electrical activity of those neurons
leads to a decrease in firing the GQ
dread in the middle panel leads to an
increase in activity and increase in
firing and increase in eating and then
simultaneously to our paper a very nice
paper by Scotts Dirksen's lab a Ponty at
all which was published in Nature
neurosciences with opto genetic
technologies where rather than an
increase in spontaneous electrical
activity sort of more physiological way
of stimulating neural activity days opto
genetics have this very nice
artificially nice burst of firing but
again regardless of the stimulation the
effect on feeding was was virtually
identical
and that it was nice to basically see
this finding that activating these AG RP
neurons these robust in increase in
feeding with that independently by opto
and chemo genetics now now since then
one of the things that that I've been
very interested in is and others others
in the in the field are interested in is
whether the information encoded by opto
or chemo genetic activation or
inhibition of neurons is similar or
different and as I said if we just go
back here one of the one of the things
that's very characteristic of
optogenetic stimulation is that it's
rapid and it's rapidly reversible but
it's highly artificial and by contrast
the stimulation afforded with chemo
genetic actuators is it's more it's more
natural type of stimulation but it tends
to be more prolonged than optogenetic
stimulation so because in one case you
you essentially get an asynchronous type
of stimulation with chemo genetics and a
synchronous type of stimulation with
optogenetics the question has come up as
to whether these are conveying different
sorts of information to the neurons of
interest and what I've done here is
summarized a large number of studies
primarily looking at feeding although
there are some studies also looking at
wakefulness where the same neurons were
interrogated sometimes in the same paper
sometimes in different paper either with
optogenetic or chemo genetic
technologies and what you can see in
every cases is is whether the whether
the neurons are turned on with chemo
genetics or or with optogenetics or
turned off with optogenetics or chemo
genetics the ultimate outcome in terms
of the physiology is is absolutely
identical and I think one of the things
that this suggests to me is that the
the frequency of stimulation or
inhibition is not so does not appear to
be so essential for these particular
behaviors as basically whether whether
the neuron has turned on or off and here
are the reference for references for
those papers for those of you that are
that are interested in in looking at
this and there are more of these these
papers coming out every day and as I
said I think these will be available for
you to download at the end of the talk
well since that time a huge number of
papers have been have been published
using both opto and kemo genetic
approaches to deconstruct the circuits
involved in feeding and I've sort of
summarized a lot of those results here
and you can see from recent papers where
that information might be found and one
of the things that was suggested by this
is that GQ coupled receptors
particularly in pom c neurons so GQ
coupled receptor activation would
increase pom C neurons
will result in decreased feeding and it
turns out in fact this is true in that
there's a recently approved anti-obesity
drug law Catherine which is a selective
agent for the 5-htt to z GQ coupled
receptor which decreases feeding so this
shows how basically how it one can use
this information to either validate or
create new new medications for a diverse
array of disorders the other thing that
this reminds me to make the point of is
that one of the again one of the nice
things about chemo genetic technology is
that is that if you get an effect in the
particular circuit that you're looking
at what this what this implies basically
is that is that all the machinery is is
available in that in that circuit
endogenous ly2 to mediate that effect
because the activation is occurring
through g-protein coupled receptors so
this has led so there are as I'll show
you now many many of these papers that
have been that have been published
and one of the things that that we've
been wondering is how far this
technology can go and I'm going to be
talking in the rest of the talk about
recent studies that have been done by
others using chemo genetic technology so
one thing is that novel dreads might be
available there's a question here
Victoria tuner is it known if the firing
patterns vary greatly between anatomical
areas or within a given area is it
knowing which of the two stimulation
patterns you show is more similar to
unmodified activity so this has not been
this is a great question it's not been
looked at in any great detail and I
think would be is a group is a great
thing to look at i I sort of just looked
at this looked at this data
retrospectively and have sort of been
support it's been a little surprising to
me that the results from these
technologies line up so so perfectly
there is one area in which this might be
a difference and that is with dopamine
neurons where it's things suggested that
tonic verses burst firing might encode
different sorts of information but I
think this is a it's a great area for
further study but getting back to the
talk here one of the one of the things
that we've been very interested in is
how far this technology can go the the
overall approach of directed molecular
evolution certainly suggests that one
could develop dozens of dreads and this
is something my lab is actively engaged
in and we will soon be revealing a novel
dread which is not activated by C and
although not today as well as dreads for
diverse signaling pathways one of the
nice things about chemo genetic
technology is that the chemical actual
leaders are highly selective and so one
one potentially could have hundreds of
these in a single Mouse here's another
question can you comment on the
possibility that CNO is back metabolized
I'll beginning to that in just a minute
if you hold on the other so it's not
back metabolized in in rodents the other
question is whether this technology can
be used in in other cells so there are
many papers now using it in other cells
beta beta cells in the pancreas
astrocytes neurons as well as for
therapies for example gene therapy into
engineering and pre evaluation of gpcr
signaling before drug discovery so these
are these are areas that were actively
engaged in in thinking about these
technologies in terms of publications we
appear to be in the growth phase of
dread adoption by the scientific
community now close to a thousand papers
yes is anything known about g IG sgq
dependent modes of intracellular
signaling by dreads EG by the beta
resting pathway yes it appears that the
so it appears that the effects that are
mediated by the GI the GQ and the GS
threads at least as far as we've been
able to determine our entirely media by
g-protein signaling and not at all by
arresting signaling although they do
activated residents to some extent we
actually have created dreads that only
activate at rest in signaling and some
of this has been published and other
others of this is is basically in
submission and it'll be interesting to
see if if a rest in signaling is
specific but right now it seems like
everything that that we've been able to
see so far is directly related to arrest
and signaling and Morris or g-protein
signaling and more specifically to
whether neuronal firing is increased or
decreased but as I said we're now sort
of in the exponential growth phase here
and one or two papers a day basically
are coming out using Dredd technology so
it's been highly highly adopted what I'd
like to do in the last part of the talk
is just
about three therapeutic applications of
dreads that have come to my attention
these have all been published by others
these are papers that were published
last year and in this year there are
multiple papers published in science
nature and cell using dreads for sort of
therapeutic and basic science
technologies and the first one of the
one of the approaches is to use dreads
to silence seizures and other yes to use
them in relation to tissue engineering
is an IPS cell technology and finally
what I'm not going to be talking about
today but is is modulating stroke
recovery and there are many others of
these papers these are just a couple
that I decided to highlight today
because they were particularly
interesting to me the first thing is
this very nice paper that was published
by the nyah broccoli and others in the
Journal of Clinical Investigation and
one of the things I like to point out
here is that I have nothing to do with
these papers I'm not an author on these
papers these are just things that have
been published by others using the
technology we developed and so this this
is the idea that of course Parkinson's
disease is a devastating disease of
catastrophic proportions where dopamine
neurons degenerate there there has been
the idea around for some time now that
one could through IPS cell technology
create new dopamine neurons put them
back in the brain and reverse and
deficits the problem with this has been
that when the transplanted dopamine
neurons are put in the brain they're
either too active and induced
dyskinesias and the patients or they're
not active enough of it the patients are
still symptomatic well the idea that the
dis group had was one why don't you put
the dreads in in the fibroblasts before
or in the neuro blast before they're
differentiated into neurons and then
you'd be able to control their activity
once they're transplanted and
so that's what they did here when they
when they had th reprogrammed cells they
they put into dreads put them in in the
brain and what they were able to show
very nicely was that the neuro blast
once they were transformed to neurons
the GQ dread increased burst firing very
similar to what occurs in slices and the
G I'd read basically induced neuronal
silencing and as well as you might as
you might guess when the dopamine
neurons show enhanced firing by GQ
signaling they'll show and also show
enhanced release of dopamine both in
vitro and in vivo by micro dialysis so
here is cyclic voltammetry results in
vivo you can see very nice increase by
CNO of in vivo dopamine being released
so they the dreads work in vivo and as
well this has functional outcomes on on
motoric behavior so they're able to
basically decrease the symptoms of
Parkinson's disease by decrease by
increasing the activity of dopamine
neurons or worsen it and so the
significance I think of this going
forward is that for tissue engineering
projects what what one would want to
have ideally is some way of gaining
remote control over these after they're
in a tissue of interest and a very nice
way to do this is with chemo genetic
technology because basically all you'd
have to do is have the person take a
pill to either increase or decrease the
activity the other paper I'd like to
just briefly describe is this one here
published by Kuhlman's group and this
relates to chemo genetic attenuation of
seizures of course seizure disorders are
can be very difficult to control
and one of the earliest therapeutic
applications of dread technology would
likely be in controlling intractable
seizures and basically what they showed
was that when the dread was expressed in
in the area of the brain in which there
was a seizure
seizure focus there was basically again
a decrease in excitability here and then
a great a great decrease in spontaneous
seizure activity so this is this is I
think a pilocarpine induce seizure here
you can see the seizure activity on the
top and then in a mouse which were rat
that was given CNO basically no no
seizure propagation so the idea here is
that using gene therapy one could
express the inhibitory dread directly in
the seizure focus and then basically
turn it off with a cat with a small
molecule extra catch you later finally
I'm just going to skip forward a couple
because we're we're sort of running out
of time here and I want to get to some
of the new chemistry and other
technologies that that we've created I
want to talk briefly about
neuropsychiatric disorders this is some
unpublished data and the idea is perhaps
we could use this technology for mood
disorders and so a typical idea one
might have would be to remotely control
serotonergic neurons and so we again use
this this flex based delivery system in
this case we're going to be expressing
them only in in the dorsal raphe using
mice that create that expressing create
recombination to control of a search
promoter get expression there
in fact this worked very very well you
can see here we're going to get through
targeted expression of the dread we are
able to get expression only in in the
dorsal raphe and these were serotonergic
neurons and and when these were
chronically activated we had a new state
robust antidepressant phenotype as
measured by a number of of outcomes one
is latency to feed so this is novelty
suppress feeding was was suppressed to a
highly significant extent there was a
great increase in as you can see
serotonin neurotransmission based on
microdialysis measurements of serotonin
as well as its metabolites five hiaa
some effects on a novel object
recognition actually enhancement of
novel object recognition as well as
amelioration of depressive phenotypes in
a number of animal models so again
suggesting that that one can use this
this technology for therapeutic
applications in which specific neuronal
populations are are shown to be altered
in a specific disease as well we were
able to use PET imaging to identify the
circuits that that might be activated or
inhibited and that's shown here and I
have a question here see what the
question is desensitization have you
know so the question is have you
observed such phenomena following
chronic CNO administration
desensitization no we haven't actually
and if we go back here to this paper
this work here we actually I don't have
the data here in this particular
presentation I guess you have to take my
word for it but what we what we did was
we made slices from mice that had been
treated with CNO for 45 days and if
anything there was a slight
sensitization so the opposite or
desensitization and the reason that this
is is likely because we're in a
condition of receptor reserve we
basically have an excess of receptors
and they can't be be desensitized to any
to any great extent so one of the one of
the potential problems with with CNO in
particular is that its effects tend to
relatively long-lasting and mice another
question here have dreads in use to
interrogate the role of neuronal
activity during development no I'm not
aware of any I'm aware of many people
that are doing the experiments I'm not
aware of anybody that's published that
the results yet so one of the problems
with CNO is that it has relatively
prolonged pharmacokinetics and the
effects can be long lasting the other
problem is this question of inter
conversion of clozapine and oxide in CNO
and so we've gone to great efforts to to
investigate this now one of the things
that we found is that in rodents there
is no back metabolism clozapine to see
you know so we published this data and
it can be found in the in the supplement
of this paper here we're basically
formal pharmacokinetic studies were done
with CNO in rodents and CNO and
clozapine were measured by lc-ms and
there basically was no clozapine that
was that was discovered I get this
question a lot and I always like to
point out that of course we go up into
this and it doesn't occur but at least
in rats and mice it doesn't Kerr in
humans and primates and so this this
could be a problem going forward and so
what we have done in this data is now
published it's online now is we've
created a number of peripherally active
both peripherally and centrally active
and non meta meta lyza Baleno logs of
CNO and those are shown here and can be
found in this paper and they have here
here's an interesting one here for those
of you who are chemists this is
deuterium
analog of CNO and basically is not
metabolized because of the what's called
the deuterium isotope effect so it's
it's not a substrate for the the SIP
because of deuterium they're so
interesting bit of chemistry the other
thing we found was that there is an
approved drug / Lapine which is about
10,000 fold selectively for the dreads
which is extremely effective at
activating the m3 and the m4 dreads and
because it's an approved drug actually
could be used for studies of dreads in
humans and has no essentially no active
metabolites and will be very good for
going forward as well these these
particular analogs here will be highly
useful and we're making them available
to individuals that may be doing studies
with crime eighths where the BAC
metabolism of CNO could be a potential
problem the other thing we've done is
we've made photo activated CNO analogs
one of these is shown here where you
might want precise spatial temporal
control of GPCR signaling both in vitro
and in vivo we haven't we haven't
published these yet but those will be
probably published relatively soon
finally we thought it would be
interesting to have dreads that are
targeted to specific neuronal domains so
we and others have made axonal II and
dendritic lis targeted dreads and they
work quite well and the dendritic
targeting dread actually not only
targets dreads to the somatic dendritic
portion but also targets them to neural
spines and we've been thinking it'd be
an interesting study to use a photo
activated CNO to activate GPCR signaling
in individual spines and see see what
effect that has on overalls find a spine
dynamics
things but so we have these and these
are also available and in combination
with photoactivation couldn't she mili
second control of signaling in
individual spines I think this is an
unprecedented level of spatial temporal
control now dreads are basically a type
of synthetic biology technology as I
said because these allow these rely on
chemical actuators a potentially
infinite combination of dreads and small
molecules could be could be developed
and thanks to the brain initiative this
is this is something we're undertaking
right now approaches to create large
numbers of dreads perhaps hundreds of
different derived chemical actuator
combinations and one can imagine them
being able to interrogate hundreds of
different neuronal subtypes sequentially
in attack in intact freely moving
animals and that would be truly
something that can't be done with any
other technology any other technological
platform could never be done optically
and so we can take advantage of
chemistry for that for that purpose if I
can just go back here I have a couple
minutes the other the other thing that
is making this possible is the
revolution that's currently going on in
GPC our structural biology which my lab
has a part in now the other thing that's
nice about the technologies is dreads
reveal their pathways responsible for
modulating neuronal signaling as I said
if a dread causes an effect in that
you're on it's likely that there's a
GPCR there that's druggable but also
does the same thing
they're also equally useful in
non-neuronal cells that are now dozens
and dozens of papers showing this and
they have the potential for therapeutics
I showed you seizures IPS cell base
therapeutics and potentially in
neuropsychiatric disorders and
the idea is that this technology will
allow us to gain a detailed
understanding of circuits in the brain
that are responsible for
neuropsychiatric disorders and that
ultimately when the brain initiative is
successful we will understand the
circuits and the particular circuitry
derived alterations that are that are
responsible for many many diseases for
which we currently have no treatments
and and the ideas that we'll be able to
intervene in those diseases in a
therapeutic way using using chemo
genetic technology so that's that's the
idea so I want to thank the various
people that that have have been involved
in this work
Blayne Armbruster currently is at merck
Sereno yíall Barty who has created a new
dread unfortunately didn't have time to
talk about that today but I'm informed
that it's impressed in neuron so it
should be coming out soon he's now at
Merck Sarah Rogan now at utmb and Dan
urban who's now at n cats at the NIH and
of course Jim McNamara do George
Alexander rad Lowell Harvard and my
crashes who now has his own lab at NIH
and as well the funding agencies so all
all the work that's currently ongoing in
my lab related to dreads is funded by
the NIH brain initiative I thank them
very much for this
and the key initial funding for the
dread technology was actually obtained
by NARS and they gave me the initial
grant that allowed us to develop the
initial grants and then subsequently
this work has been funded by the NIH so
we have about four and a half minutes
left I think I've answered all the
questions if there are any other
questions we have a few minutes to go
and I'm happy to answer anything else or
if you felt the answers that I gave were
not sufficient the other thing that I
just like to mention is that
I have a blog here let me just give you
the address of the blog here just
copying it here see yours if I can
here's a question do dreads interact
with other GPCRs to form hetero dimers
no they don't as far as we know so this
is something we've spent a fair amount
of time looking at at least nothing that
we can validate so it's a question I get
a lot as far as we know no other people
have published a very nice study has was
done by Graham Milligan which has
published published two papers one in
molecular farm the other in JVC
basically negative data so so as far as
we know no and that's all we know yes
other question here are you inducing
glutamate receptor to induce GQ
signaling and pyramidal neurons no
probably not
this is likely through the p i-- through
alteration of fossil and hospitai
signaling another question have you done
any work looking at what the actions of
dreads on GS glycogen synthase kinase 3
beta we haven't we haven't looked at
that pathway great question no okay what
I'm going to do is I'm going to I'm
sending the blog to the organizers here
and I would ask them that they post this
with my talk I get lots of questions
related to dread technology
and I usually put the answers on the
blog so if any questions should come up
after the talk today or those of you
they're working with threads if you have
questions you can just go to the blog
and and they're the answers okay is
there any immune response to dreads that
could be problematic in their
application to gene therapy no not that
we know of and we've looked at this and
we haven't seen any immunological
response in any rodents and/or in we've
also looked in in monkeys so a number of
people have used dread technology and
monkeys and we specifically looked for
evidence any untoward and you know a
reactive effect and there aren't any
likely because these are human receptors
so you wouldn't expect them to it's not
like we're using a bacterial product
okay a great question click on the white
boards I did this the text tool yeah
okay other question here as anyone
evaluating how robust VI is and against
preventing spike the less spiking
elicited by optogenetic input yeah there
are lots of papers on this the best
paper is actually a paper by Scott
Stenson that was published in neuron
last year where they looked at spiking
and release and I my lab I wrote a
little perspective on it so if you go to
Scott Stearns paper that's probably the
best and
all right so we're out of time so thank
you very much and I'm going to leave I
unfortunately we are out of time I want
to thank the audience for their
interesting questions and participation
in today's event and our speaker dr.
Brian Roth for his informative
presentation today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing for
several months following you'll receive
an email from lab roots alerting you
when this webcast will be available for
replay I mean by you'd afford that
announcement to your colleagues who have
missed today's live event see you next
time goodbye